[Music]
hello everyone its Alicia Malone this is
another Fandango indie movie guide and
we are really getting into award season
now so I have two films that I'm sure
we're going to be talking about when it
comes to best pictures possibly best
actors as well let's start with one of
my favorites of the year might even be
my favorite I've seen it three times now
it's called call me by your name so what
are you doing running read books
transcribe music swim at the river go
out at night sounds fun alright later
this is directed by Luca Guadagnino who
is the Italian director behind I am love
and a bigger splash it stars army hammer
and Timothy sha'lame hey Timothy plays a
young man living in Italy with his
family in the 80s and along comes army
hammers character an American student
who is staying with his family the two
fall in love over summer it is a
sensuous beautiful elegantly told story
performances are wonderful are me and
Timothy have a great chemistry together
and it is a heartbreaking story that
everyone can relate to
I just can't describe how beautiful this
film is see just gonna have to see it
and experience it for yourself call me
by your name is available in theaters
from this weekend probably see it for a
fourth time another movie I really
enjoyed that's gonna be up there when it
comes to awards contention is darkest
hour directed by Joe Wright starring the
brilliant Gary Oldman he plays Winston
Churchill at the moment when he became
prime minister just as the world was
going into World War two but Winston
Churchill was quite a humorous man and
he was known for his great quips his
quotes his speeches and Gary Oldman
definitely gets that twinkle in his eye
she's an actor love with the sound of
his own voice Gary Oldman is
unrecognizable as Winston Churchill I
think this is the best human prosthetic
makeup that I have ever seen on screen
but more than just makeup acting he
transforms his entire body and at this
point I would say he is the only
frontrunner when it comes to the Best
Lead Actor category it's a fascinating
story it's beautifully directed by Joe
who also did atonement and Pride and
Prejudice and features Ben Mendelsohn
not in a villain role for once he's
playing King George the sixth this could
also make a great double feature
alongside Dunkirk because they both
explore the same point in history but
from very different perspectives you
cannot reason with a tiger
when your head is
oh I take full responsibility really yes
it is the reason I sit in this chair
definitely see darkest hour it's
available in cinemas from this weekend
for Williams victory there can be no Sun
and then three quick recommendations on
Fandango now if you want to stay home
and relax this weekend or over
Thanksgiving break but first is a
documentary called kitty and it's about
seven cats who live on Istanbul streets
just seven of these thousands of cats
that roam the streets of Istanbul and it
is so cute to watch I love this movie if
you enjoy cats and you want a bit of joy
in your life I cannot recommend Kitty
enough
[Music]
Briggs b-bear is also available on
Fandango now this starring Kyle Mooney
as a guy who was kidnapped when he was
young and emerges to the world as an
adult but not knowing anything about the
current world it is funny and sweet
without being sentimental also features
Mark Hamill in the cast
Briggs me bear a really good pick for
your home watching just be normal
hi I'm James I really close and you can
also see Logan lucky on Fandango now if
you miss this one in cinemas I recommend
watching it it's directed by Steven
Soderbergh and stars Channing Tatum
Daniel Craig Adam driver Riley Keough
and many more it is a heist film set in
the world of NASCAR racing they call it
oceans 7-eleven out meaning that in any
kind of derogatory way because it
definitely shows that the smartest
people might not be the ones you expect
I love putting together his heist movies
they come together like a jigsaw and
then you keep thinking about them for
hours afterwards
[Music]
you movin must be as simple mad and as
people say people say that so if you're
venturing out into the theaters see call
me by your name or darkest hour or if
you're staying at home I recommend Teddy
Briggs be bear or Logan lucky
I'm Alicia Malone Happy Thanksgiving
once again and I will see you next week
[Music]